Latin America does matter that it will
play an important role in the 21st
century
at this moment Latin America represents
600 million people total GDP of over 6
trillion u.s. dollars it is connected
internationally globally we have three
countries Brazil Mexico and Argentina
that are a member of the g20 Club we
have natural resources oil metals
foodstuff that makes us an important
economic player so Latin America has its
own place in terms of its relationship
with the u.s. it is close it has always
been historically close and there is a
common agenda that deals with economic
and trade issues but also environment it
has to do with drug trafficking with
safety there's a whole set of issues
that bind together Latin America and the
United States and thirdly there is the
presence of Latinos in the United States
at this moment fifty two million Latinos
live in the u.s. it is projected that by
2050 there will be 130 million Latinos
living in the US so this will be a
decisive force in politics in economics
socially culturally so my take would be
that pay attention to Latin America and
Latinos in the US because they will be
influential in the years to come